[Music]
and what love hot news
oh you caused it submitted by suitable I
love [ __ ] to Debrecen last time we
had that [ __ ] man Oh summertime that's I
when it's one a time I like I said the
booth one of the Paltrow's lifestyle
brand is getting called out for
ridiculous products being sold on her
website word I ain't even a shadow
without sell Frances balance bracelet
I heard it's popular it's called goop
goop I thought it was cool so she has a
website it's called like a lifestyle
brand because on this website there's a
blog post where it can give you advice
on like how to take care of yourself or
recipes on what to cook or fashion
advice and they also have like a store
where they curate a lot of products from
all over everywhere other companies and
then they sell it on their store and
they also have their own brand where
they have like creams and stuff creams
and lotions mmm is like soft cream
gotcha
scent was called group with Gwyneth
Paltrow baby she started back in 2008
and so over the years she's been called
out for a lot of ridiculous should that
she claims is even like her spore like
is she a part of it or she just like the
face of a did someone's running it
most likely the latter because you've
got sitting there clicking around like
well now I'm going to sell this product
they do mention that there is a team
behind this website obviously she can do
this all alone because I think the team
needs to be fired why because they're
giving her a bad name yeah they're
because but she does also believe in
like a lot of the stuff that they claim
so that is all magic with the crap yeah
like all Mark I hate that [ __ ] crystal
Ely [ __ ] the rock
do you [ __ ] you know about this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] balance wristing yeah
if I push on you you with your push you
got the sin of balance better so but if
you take it off Oh
Oh yo over mariel at the Glendale mall
and the person was doing the balancing
no no no it was it was they trying to do
it on me uh Mary I wanted to buy it
let's just see it so she just I want you
to stick it I'll push you down and watch
you fall over she goes she can't move as
you do you have a really good center of
balance
unlike know your product doesn't work
just don't mean I'm like no it's like
you try to sell [ __ ] the people do
this make a little [ __ ] or $50 I'm gonna
give you this magical bracelet that's
going to make you Center your [ __ ]
energy
yeah look I feel myself getting better
already
oh yeah especially I face a long time
because I know a lot of those hippie
Burning Man types from when i skogen in
my plant signs i put rose quartz in the
soil to help it grow and we did oh I
feel like I'm getting cancer let me put
that [ __ ] there's also whoa yeah
where they said of you you take this
polish on a rose quartz whatever if you
have like vaginal problems will pick up
their Jade Jade or some [ __ ] yes that
one's actual true though there's
something Chinese in there forks stick
something like a Chinese man yeah the
most recent product that she was getting
criticized for is these healing stickers
hmm killing stickers awesome they're
sold by a company named body vibes and
so it's $60 four pack of it handy that's
so cheap what is it like xalapa oh
that's a healing stick I love that [ __ ]
that I'll buy that Costco and it's like
like menthol a tits are like tiger balm
on a sticker just put it on and just you
know do not put that in your inner
thighs burns your vagina's yeah so these
are the stickers it looks like this how
come it's always white people everyone
else knows better
this is a beautiful white girl that's
like come on I mean it's those those
stickers like that kind of like holistic
approach to oh wait a beautiful white
woman it's because Asians been getting
conned yeah we know
[ __ ] it's kind of like you can you can't
[ __ ] try to sell me a piece of snow
that's my grandma has been full doing
that [ __ ] this is a new to them yeah so
these stickers they claim to be made of
the same conductive carbon material that
nASA uses to line spacesuits and so they
was I mean what does that do it for you
so they're saying that this lining can
monitor the astronauts vitals during its
wear yeah so they're also claiming that
these stickers are pre-programmed to an
ideal frequency to rebalance our bump
see what does that mean I'll give you a
little bit more so they're saying that
it's missus filling the deficiencies in
your reserves creating a calming effect
what is that meaning out both physical
tension and anxiety see here's the thing
- like every time you hear these type of
products or when people try to put
something on you you guys take things as
facts when you don't even know what the
[ __ ] they're describing what the [ __ ] is
the reserve yeah like what is that what
is the frequency it's like when somebody
told me this they're like okay you
should be a vegan because of your
alkalis not like what's an alkaline
teacher selling with you know I will
just explain to me what you said to me
so I could understand it I wasn't even
being angry I just wanted to know what
he was saying he's just using words and
he goes dude made the [ __ ] that
alkaline your body's all [ __ ] up your
eating me
oh my cool what's an alkaline just anger
it it's like they're banking on people
who are so stupid that then when they
see them very descriptive long words
like that sounds fancy I'm down like if
you go to a restaurant absolutely just
the steak they put like 14 different
words to describe it you like that
sounds amazing and one of that one
there's a lot of people offering it's
like the holistic I think world like
they have to adjust their wording for
the why people market so they have to
make it sound scientific and then use
like words that sound like really
interesting and oh that sounds like it's
legit but I think that's what they got
to do because Asian people do the other
stuff they'll be like you know what this
is going to make your dragon energy very
strong yeah and you want you want the
you know Tigers like you you want you
want to be strong like a tiger then you
take this pill I think
I think they got to just market their
[ __ ] [ __ ] depending on the
culture usually the Asian ones they just
have like an old man with the whiskers
coming out yeah and then calligraphy on
the side and you know it's legit and if
it smells like [ __ ] this [ __ ] right
here and if it if it's packaged like in
a nineteen 1923 bottle like [ __ ] [ __ ]
like this that's how you know it's legit
mmm I guess that word reserved like
reserved what what what is in your
reserves what were you talking about and
people will use that phrase like on
people like us and expect us to
understand what the [ __ ] they're talking
about that bro try this
you mean stored in your reserves
reserved for what you know your
frequency reserves no NASA came out
saying you have to call to hear what a
waste of massive time not really
GUP is more the company because it isn't
group manager so what are their products
on their site yeah exactly so the former
chief scientist at NASA says they don't
use carbon material in spacesuits quote
what a load of BS thank you group ended
up removing the frequency stickers no so
this is the group ended up Rihanna's
ended up removing the stickers and they
also retracted the claims of that
company from body vibes they ended up
saying quote as we have always explained
advice and recommendations included on
group are not formal endorsements and
the opinions expressed by the experts
and companies we profile do not
necessarily represent the views of group
our content is meant to highlight unique
products and offering client open-minded
alternative and encourage conversation
we constantly start to improve our site
for our readers and are continuing to
improve our processes for evaluating the
products and companies features based on
the statement from NASA we've gone back
to the company to inquire about the
claim and remove the claim from our site
until we get additional verification mmm
I just don't like apology was too wordy
man I I woulda just wrote this yo now
she's crazy we [ __ ] on my bad job
you'll come back next time we will bring
any of this [ __ ] garbage coming from
granite-- ostracism from good the goop
stares like yo my bad about that oh [ __ ]
look tired Damon should be PR for your
company perfect because at least when I
apologize I thought
that's how I do it or if I'm adamant
about my belief I just tell you [ __ ] off
you know but either way it's honesty so
much are you guys a few images and these
are other claims coming from goop that
are meant to help you but it's either
help or ridiculously stupid expensive
products that are are they are they just
going to like China India and getting
these old things and then coming back to
the states and selling them like it I
don't know how they're getting it but oh
here's that because some of these things
are just like fake we've got a toilet
seat cover No
yes this is a toilet seat and so one of
groups claims a saying that women should
go get vagina or vaginal steams whoa a
vaginal steam yeah so it's like this
like toilet where it's a hole and then
like this too but then gynecologists
came out say I'm liable don't do that
you're gonna ruin your flora and it's
just gonna [ __ ] your lady horns up but
all these extra sweaty you know the
reasons they don't question I was
pictured you would wash it after yeah I
mean I thought you just kind of steamed
it away sauna for your weekend that's
one your [ __ ] is not a dumpling told
Ephesian nice so healing stones like a
river rock there's also this Jade egg
you were talking about what if you get
stuck in your vagina how do you know
there's no streamers in yank it out
position 18 carat golden dumbbells I go
for 125 thousand dollars but you don't
understand though it's gold it has good
energy 1125 thousand dollars you guys
know gold is a pure conductor of
electricity so when you do curls with
that it actually helps with the
homeostasis of the frequency of your
reserves you know I gotta get that
necklace that that's why even if it's
only one pound your biceps think that
it's play it's doing like 50 pounds
you're burning more calories you do with
less reps because it's gold I need to
buy that now yep a toothpaste squeezer
yeah that's going to that's going to
clear a chocolate toothpaste squeezer I
was going for two hundred and forty five
dollars about a little plastic ones too
hundreds around or you can just start
from the end and just roll it up with
the fingers that one infuses your
toothpaste with good energy it's
supposed to clear all of your chakras
and all the nether regions it's not
fluoride activator yes the next product
is a bone in a box it's toilet paper
wrapped in that so inconvenient to use
and then there's like some lotion it's
pure for your [ __ ]
it's interesting though because like
this is as this is as far as you can see
how my consumerism goes oh yeah let me
show you this next one hold on here we
go
so glad and dildo I've seen that before
that makes sense
a golden dildo the conductor of
electricity I'm down with that
more orgasmic I saw was $15,000 24 karat
golden dildo that's a bargain it's just
a gold bar now on you can melt in and do
something else I believe in that yeah
but business just some of the [ __ ] that
she sells on your site I mean like
people go plate their guns and golden
moustache on do you have any people like
that like do you know anyone that like
does that [ __ ] or imply or false without
that yeah my mom all the time just loves
it
yep yeah but you know that's that's just
kind of I mean I think we're all like
guilty of it to a certain extent and you
know consumerism is such an interesting
concept because it's literally people
buying stuff to to show status you know
so what do you have call them do you
have you know an ethical consumerism
it's like that's what that literally is
it's like you have your toothpaste
dispenser that was what five bucks no
check out mine you know did you know
this was 250 bucks and people get amazed
by that they don't look at the functions
like a museum you know oh my god you got
that the word you really I my rations
well you're [ __ ] stupid you get that
for five dollars don't make fun of my
toothpaste [ __ ] pressure makes me
feel bad because we all do that to a
certain extent too though but that was
pretty extreme you know it's like the
same [ __ ] too wide you know I have like
[ __ ] well yeah I do I have [ __ ] 40
shoes you know I mean like I'm not going
to use all but I like I like it when
it's straightforward like a luxury item
a luxury item is straightforward you're
getting this expensive piece of jewelry
because you like the way it looks
there's no function for it but it's
expensive and it looks good and whatever
you like you like it for what it is I
don't like it when people lie here's a
fun
this penny is like it's not your average
penny this penny was [ __ ] swallowed
by a yogi master and [ __ ] it out so it's
blessed by all the [ __ ] spirituals
that are in his body so it's like [ __ ]
like that I don't like that that's it's
like well [ __ ] like that that there's
why there's a shark fin soup sand
something [ __ ] like that animal is also
delicious it is kind of good though it
would taste good without the shark when
they took it out I was like it's still
mom yeah it's bomb-ass [ __ ] egg drop
soup that roll hope you guys enjoyed
that video if you did a really cool way
to communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video is by
subscribing
so click on that little subscribe button
and you'll never miss an episode for the
next episode click right up here
[Music]